welcome to Horry so bees the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and dove into newest tech products so
recently Intel once again delayed their
10 nanometer process CPUs until next
year and next year
AMD is actually coming out with their
seven nanometers CPUs with the Zen - so
as you guys can see AMD is catching up
to Intel it may overtake them very soon
but before we delve into that make sure
to hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to stay updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and pcs we
all know that Intel has been dominating
the CPU market for many years now and
AMD was just on the side but in the last
year after the release of Rison amy has
been making huge strides forward their
insane value is just absolutely
unbeatable they give you so many cores
for such a low price and on top of that
they even throw in really good CPU
coolers so it is unquestionable that AMD
is the king of value but until now Intel
has still been the best of performance
but that may soon change
Intel has been delaying the 10 nanometer
process for a really long time now like
seriously the 40 nanometer process has
been out since 2014 and intoa has
reiterated it for four generations now
this is actually what probably gave AMD
the time to be able to innovate and
catch up to Intel and make all these
huge strides forward and now that there
is competition Intel a scrambling to
innovate and obviously they're having a
tough time so after all this Intel was
supposed to come out with the 10
nanometer process and Canon like at the
end of this year but that may not be the
case anymore because at the last quarter
call they announced that the 10
nanometer process is once again delayed
into an unspecified time in 2019
meanwhile competitors like TSMC are
beginning their production of seven
animator processes already this really
brings up their question what has Intel
been doing for the last couple of years
they had so much time to perfect the 10
nanometer process because they were just
adding a couple of gigahertz to their
existing processors anyways
so they didn't really need to focus on
new
so why are you delaying it once again
coffee link came out in October of 2017
and if finto continues to release the
new CPU refresh every single year then
Kenlake should be coming out in the
October of this year but with this news
there is an issue one Kenlake will not
support the 10 nanometer process or can
Lake itself will be pushed back to 2019
either way this is not good news for
Intel
so what about AMD how are they doing
with these new processes well if you
look at the rising timeline they're
actually supposed to come out with the 7
animator process CPUs just next year so
at this point it seems as if AMD will
push out their 7 animator main stream
platform CPUs as Intel is finally coming
out with their 10 nanometer process CPUs
on the main stream platform after many
many years so as it is evident AMD is
really catching up now I know that just
because the CPU is on a smaller process
doesn't necessarily mean that it'll
perform any better but this does show
how fast AMD is developing new
technology and how fast they are
catching up to Intel and that they even
may take them over on top of all this
AMD will most likely continue to be in
tow in value and as a result they will
definitely be able to track more of the
budget CPU buyers and in the end until
needs to do one of two things either
provide better performance or better
pricing or else may they rest in peace
furthermore AMD's next generation of
rising CPUs with the 7 animator process
is expected to reach 5 gigahertz when
overclocked so if AMD starts pushing out
these octa-core CPUs for the same price
as their current flagship sat $330 with
a really good CPU cooler and it can
overclock to 5 gigahertz then I'm not
sure how Intel can come back from that
Intel is also expected to come out with
a new processor later this year however
this is just a colleague refresh and
while it may offer octa-core zand 16
threads on the mainstream platform
and maybe even five gigahertz it'll
definitely come at a premium price and
probably won't come with the stock
cooler like AMD and on top of all that
they're going to have to be forced to
buy a z3 90 motherboard as opposed AMD
who let you user their flagship CPUs on
budget oriented motherboards like the B
Series now this all sounds really dark
and gloomy and negative for Intel
but their CPUs are still really good so
should you wait well if you're
considering to buy a 8700 K then I
definitely recommend you guys wait for
the 8800 K or 9700 K fix it won't be too
much more expensive and if you guys are
looking for that type of performance
then it's definitely worth to spend a
little bit more money and get two more
cores and four more threads that new CPU
may be overclocked to 5 gigahertz so it
should be definitely a significant
upgrade however if you're struggling to
decide between waiting for Ken like next
year or the 9700 K or 8800 K in October
of this year then I don't think it
really matters because considering that
this is a new process for Intel I don't
think that's gonna make huge strides for
right the first generation and there
will also be very many bugs and problems
so there's nothing wrong with getting
the octa-core processor that Intel will
probably come out at the end of this
year but at the same time be warned
because they will be expensive also
Intel isn't going to die or anything
they have a lot of technology and they
do have lot better performance in AMD at
least at this current point and as a
result if they just simply offer their
CPUs for more reasonable or more value
oriented prices then they will
definitely keep the relief the only
issue is that they have been stagnating
for a really long time and now it seems
as if they are having trouble innovating
it any further
and as a result competitors may be able
to catch up and even overtake Intel in
the close future AMD is really
capitalizing on this weak spot for Intel
by providing a really good performance
at a really outstanding price but
through all this US consumers can just
sit back and relax and watch the war go
on and finally wants all the smoke
clears we can just simply go buy the
better CPU whether it's from AMD
or in dumb overall intel has been
slacking for quite a while now and it's
time for them to take severe action
unless they want to pay severe
consequences so what do you guys think
are you guys shooting for AMD and you
want them to put into a back in their
place or do you not care you just want
the best tip you possible make sure to
comment what you guys think in the
comments down below because I do read
all my comments and I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure to drop a like and
hit that subscribe button if you guys
would like to see more videos just like
this a reasonable day but until next
time bye
[Music]
you